scène de la vie quotidienne à kaboul
sont le plus souvent des femmes et des
enfants qui meurent sous des roquettes
tirées de trop loin par les moudjahidine
preuve de l'impuissance de la résistance
dans la capitale incapable de frapper
juste contre des cibles militaires
sept mois après le retrait des troupes
soviétiques qui devait signer son arrêt
de mort
l'homme fort du régime installé par
moscou le prix du riz ou là et toujours
chaque jour qui passe elle lui fait
gagner un peu de critiques en beauté aux
yeux du monde à la déception de beaucoup
de diplomates l'afghanistan n'est pas le
vietnam soviétique ne serait ce qu'à
cause de cette longue frontière commune
il y a une semaine un convoi de 13 cents
véhicules soviétique dont 300 chars a
gagné kandar pratiquement sans perte
tapi dans leur bunker de kaboul des
conseillers soviétiques en voie de
redoutables missiles ce code autour de
djalal abad toujours encerclée par les
budgets sept mois après le retrait du
contingent soviétique la guerre afghane
but encore extrêmement cher à moscou
mais grâce à cela les grandes villes
tiennent toujours à quelques exceptions
près taloqan aux portes de la province
de tarare le grenier à blé de kaboul
taloqan vives de 50000 habitants est
sous contrôle des modalités les
populations sont revenus le marché est
approvisionné
la vie semble presque normal même si la
menace d'un bombardement est permanente
nous sommes en plein secteur contrôlé
par le commandant massoud le seul chef
de la résistance considéré par les
soviétiques eux mêmes comme un
interlocuteur valable
les difficultés que le lion du panshir
rencontre ici qu illustre bien ces
dissensions entre factions de
moudjahidine qui elles aussi font le jeu
de kaboul le commandant d'un groupe
islamiste concurrents a fait exterminer
15 hommes de massoud
il attend son jugement en fait par delà
les dissensions les échecs militaires de
la résistance s'explique selon massoud
par trop de précipitation mediouni asic
et moudjahidine a marqué d'achat
boostant les soviétiques étaient là au
faust une élection dans une position
défensive après leur départ
il faut du temps on est repassé à
l'offensive notamment issus des
pressions diplomatiques
certes un groupe de moudjahidine se sont
lancés trop vite dans une guerre de
position il est fort à laquelle ils
n'étaient pas préparés interrompu en
novembre
l'aide américaine aux moudjahidine a
repris aujourd'hui massoud a levé une
armée de 7500 hommes parmi lesquels
curieusement sept soldats soviétiques
capturés et contraint à la guerre sainte
pour sauver leurs prix
le lion du panshir vient de lancer une
vaste offensive au nord de kaboul
mais la capitale elle même s'est dit il
pour plus tard dans un an peut-être la
guerre en afghanistan un cessez-le-feu
entre rivaux islamistes est intervenu
c'est du moins ce qu'affirme le
gouvernement pakistanais
les frères ennemis de l'islam se
seraient mis d'accord pour transférer le
pouvoir à un conseil intérimaire à
kaboul une chose est sûre ce matin les
combats fratricides continuer dans la
capitale afghane
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux à
kaboul jérôme baugnies jean-françois
hoffman trêve de courte durée le temps
d'un appel à la prière
les familles de kabou liquide ce
quartier moderne de micro ryan près de
l'aéroport
le commandant massoud du nouvel homme
fort de kaboul les a fait prévenir
qu'une opération militaire allait être
menée contre les fondamentalistes du
hezb-i-islami qui occupent certains de
ses immeubles
hélicoptère à l'appui maintenant tous
les ordres du chef des moudjahidines du
nord kaboul est aujourd'hui coupé par un
front sur la ligne de partage entre les
moudjahidine du nord et ceux du
hezb-e-islami mieux implanté au sud les
hommes de massoud repris hier cette
position au nord qui surplombe
l'aéroport de kaboul d'où décollent des
mig aujourd'hui sous les ordres de masse
de ce point élevé
ils pilonnent à l'adc à la colline d'en
face au sud occupée par le hezb-e-islami
échanges de tirs d'artillerie
par-dessus la capitale afghane allahu
akbar crient les artilleurs dieu est
grand
pourtant ils ne font plus la djihad la
guerre sainte
car il se bat contre d'autres
moudjahidine les hommes de culte
boutique nous ne nous battons pas nous
sommes pour la paix et l'unité c'est
cool boudine qui ne veut pas de l'unité
depuis le début il n'a jamais voulu la
paix entre deux feux les habitants ne
peuvent plus faire soigner leurs malades
ni leurs blessés c'est aujourd'hui le
14e anniversaire de la révolution
d'avril qui amena les communistes au
pouvoir
14 ans de guerre les enfants n'ont rien
connu d'autre la résignation afghane
fait place à la colère
nous rejetons ces combats stupide et
n'ont aucun sens des milliers de gens
sont déjà morts et enterrés
personne ne nous aide
les catholiques royer la guerre enfin
terminé en fait avec l'arrivée des
moudjahidine la guerre est entrés dans
kaboul
et encore une fois ce sont les
populations civiles qui font les frais
des intolérances et des dogmatismes
vallée du panjshir première ligne de
front dans ces montagnes se joue la
bataille pour l'afghanistan
c'est ici que se sont retranchés les
hommes du commandant massoud pour
combattre avec l'aide du relief les
finales la l'ennemi taliban
nous sommes au poste le plus avancé
quelques mètres de plus et là bas dans
le virage ce sont les talibans la fin de
l'hiver a sonné la sortie des tranchées
ce ne sont pas encore les grande
offensive de printemps
mais depuis que la neige a fondu les
journées sont rythmées par de petits
accrochages
nour hamad est un moudjahidin un
combattant son père était moudjahidine
il est tombé sous les balles de
l'occupant soviétique à l'époque
nour a mende était trop jeune pour se
battre mais aujourd'hui il est fier de
lutter en première ligne les 18 ans tu
as déjà tué des talibans
oui tu aimes les combats oui j'adore ça
depuis combien de temps combattu set en
sept ans notre traducteur a du mal à le
croire mais qu'importe son commandant en
première ligne est fier de lui
après vingt ans de combat quel sentiment
cela vous procure-t-il de voir arriver
de si jeunes moujahidines c'est très
bien sûr tout cela très bien ils sont la
relève
ses attaques répétées au mortier vont
provoquer la réplique de la deuxième
ligne répliquent à l'armé lourde
c'est l'enchaînement classique d
accrochage dans la vallée les talibans
ce sont des bêtes sauvages la plupart ne
sont que des pantins
heureusement ils ont été stoppés dans
cette vallée du panjshir avec l'aide de
dieu nous les repoussons pour l'heure la
selette qu'elle l'a semble leur apporter
c'est l'instant de la prière un répit
assuré pendant lequel les tirs s'arrête
et c'est bien là l'ironie de cette
guerre des deux côtés du front
c'est le prophète qu'ils invoquent des
deux côtés du front c'est en son nom
qu'ils combattent
le commandant massoud l'opposant aux
talibans au pouvoir en afghanistan était
à paris aujourd'hui il a été reçu par le
ministre des affaires étrangères hubert
védrine et il a lancé un appel à l'aide
philippe pisteurs pierre dick c'est
d'abord le chef militaire du seul
gouvernement afghan reconnu par la
communauté internationale que rencontré
ce matin le chef de la diplomatie
française mais au delà
ahmad shah massoud est un symbole
l'incarnation de la résistance au régime
taliban
mais une résistance en mauvaise posture
aujourd'hui confiné dans son réduit du
nord-est de l'afghanistan moins de 10%
du territoire
mais si l'on en croit massoud l'heure de
la reconquête a sonné mardi en réaction
par l'ingérence pakistanaises et aux
comportements chaque jour plus injuste
des talibans
la résistance s'organise de plus en plus
au sein du peuple dans toutes ethnies
confondues tadjikes et hazara pachtoune
ouzbek et bientôt vous serez témoin d'un
soulèvement populaire contre des
talibans
au lendemain de la destruction des
bouddhas de bamiyan et de l'émotion
qu'elle a suscitée dans le monde
cette visite la première de massoud en
europe prend bien sûr un relief tout
particulier au président de l'assemblée
nationale comme à chacun de ses
interlocuteurs politiques
il martèle le même message l'europe les
etats-unis doivent faire pression sur le
pakistan principal soutien des talibans
dans le même temps il lance un appel à
l'aide internationale pour les réfugiés
afghans cohue médiatique partout où il
passe
l'homme suscite un véritable engouement
rencontre impromptue avec yvette roudy
beaucoup sur hbo pour des grands demain
direction strasbourg le parlement
européen recevra celui que le mythe
surnomme le lion du panshir le
commandant massoud ne scrute aura plus
les montagnes du pays
cette région du nord-est de
l'afghanistan était devenu son fièvre
c'est là qu'il s'était repliée depuis la
prise de kaboul par les talibans les
étudiants en théologie en 1996 mais
avant d'être le chef de file de
l'opposition en tout cas liban massoud
avait été le héros de la résistance à
l'envahisseur soviétique
cette guerre qui avait duré de 1979 à
1989 avait fait près d'un million de
morts en 1992 il entrait en triomphateur
dans kaboul ministre de la défense
durant un an il avait cependant
abandonner la politique pour reprendre
les armes et défendre la capitale contre
les différentes factions armées afghanes
qui tentaient de s'approprier
les en 1996 il a été chassé laissant
derrière lui une ville détruite
il réussira pourtant a regroupé autour
de lui quelques chefs de guerre et à
incarner une alternative ominami mois
d'avril tentaient encore de rallier à sa
cause d'européens gains et visite à
rabat paris et parlement de strasbourg
mais il repart ni dans la combustion du
punch ir sans avoir obtenu un réel
soutien de la part des européens
ce n'est pas encore officiel mais tout
porte à croire ce soir que le commandant
massoud est mort plusieurs sources
confirment son décès le chef militaire
de l'opposition afghane avait été très
grièvement blessé par l'explosion d'une
caméra piégés dimanche dernier ce
n'était pas un acte isolé le lien est
désormais établi entre cet attentat et
ceux commis 48 heures plus tard à new
york et à washington par les dinos l'une
des dernières interviews du commandant
massoud
ce jour-là il recevait un sénateur et
des journalistes français le 10
septembre dernier il accorde un nouvel
entretien à ces deux hommes qui
prétendent être des journalistes d'une
agence de télévision arabes
c'est alors qu'ils font exploser une
ceinture bourrée d'explosifs le
commandant massoud et grièvement blessé
un moscou et washington ont le donnent
pour mort ses proches démentent
mais cet après midi dans la vallée du
panjshir des informations alarmistes
circuler affirmation mais
vraisemblablement plus plus les en
avance et plus le décès du commandant
massoud a annoncé d'accord et on
parlerait même de retour de
de sa dépouille dans sa ville d'origine
vos oracle dans les heures qui viennent
il y à quelques instants lagence
islamique afghane une agence de presse
proche des taliban annoncé la mort du
commandant une information qui pour le
moment n'a pas été officiellement
confirmée par les porte-paroles de
massoud
mais ce matin cet homme le commandant
farine a été désigné par les autres
chefs de guerre pour prendre la tête de
l'opposition armée aux talibans
en europe l'enquète progresse sur
l'assassinât du commandant massoud une
dizaine d'arrestations en belgique et
deux en france l'une à paris l'autre
dans le nord
olivier caroff marianne masse tournée
avec une petite caméra amateur la scène
paraît presque anodine en fait c'est
bien une arrestation qui vient de se
produire dans les rues de bruxelles
au petit matin en tout la police belge a
mis la main sur une dizaine de personnes
à chaque fois les policiers sont
repartis avec d'importantes quantités de
documents et des ordinateurs des
suspects
ce qu'ils espèrent y trouver des liens
avec les réseaux terroristes d'oussama
ben laden et surtout avec l'assassinât
en afghanistan le 9 septembre dernier du
commandant massoud ennemis irréductibles
des talibans il avait été tué par un
commando terroriste
deux hommes qui s'étaient fait passer
pour des journalistes dans l'hélicoptère
qui les menait à leur cible
il avait été filmé par hasard
les voici au fond de l'appareil leur
lien avec la belgique
leurs passeports des faux documents qui
ressemble beaucoup à d'autres saisies en
décembre 2000 à calais et simplement les
personnes qui y compteraient la mort
lors de l'assassinât de massoud ce
compte était un chef le moment en
possession de faux passeports belges
dans la même série que les pages projet
à calais qui a fabriqué ces faux papiers
la justice belge le dirach les services
de renseignement et e.on ont déjà leur
petite idée
ici en france à la dst on a coopéré avec
les belges résultat deux nouvelles
arrestations ce matin des suspects liés
au réseau ben laden
on retrouve la trace de ces deux hommes
un peu partout en europe et
particulièrement en allemagne
l'allemagne
le point de départ des kamikazes du
world trade center
[Musique]